Dave, the last star will die and
the universe will turn dark forever.
It will probably be a red dwarf,
a tiny kind of start.
That's also one of our best bet is to
find alien life and might be the last home
of humanity before the
university becomes uninhabitable.
So what do we know about them
and why are they our last hope?
At least 70% of stars in
the universe are red dwarfs.
They are the tiniest stars out there with
only about seven to 50% of the mass of
our sun, not that much bigger than our
planet Jupiter, which is still huge.
Though they are also very dim.
It's impossible to see
them with the naked eye.
You've never seen one in the night sky.
Even with all our technology,
we can only clear the observe.
Red Dwarfs in our neighborhood,
approximately 20 of the 30 stars close
to Earth are red dwarfs like all stars.
Red Dwarfs fuse hydrogen into helium.
But while more massive stars accumulate
all the fuse helium in there,
cause red dwarfs stay convective,
meaning that the helium and
hydrogen constantly mix,
so they use up their fuel incredibly
slowly before they're extinguished.
Red Dwarfs burn so slowly that that
average lifespan is between one and 10
trillion years.
By comparison,
the Sun will survive for another 5 billion
years because the university is only
13.7 5 billion years old.
Not a single red dwarf has reached
a later development stages.
Every single one of the trillions
that exist is still a baby.
Speaking of babies,
the smallest star and the entire universe
is also a red wolf because small red
dwarfs are right on the
verge of being a star at all,
just a tiny bit less
hydrogen and they own bear.
Brown dwarfs failed stars that cannot
sustain a fusion reaction for long.
So what about aliens or
a new home for humanity?
Since our son will die one day will
eventually need to look for a new home and
where there are habitable planet,
there might also be aliens.
The Kepler space observatory found that
at least half of all red dwarfs host
rock planet between half and
four times the mass of our earth.
Many of them are in the habitable zone,
the area around a style
where water can be liquid,
but since red dwarves Burnet
relatively cold temperatures,
that would need to be really
close to be hospitable,
probably as close as mercury
to our son or even closer,
which brings with it all kinds
of problems. For example,
a planet this close to a style
would probably be tidally locked,
meaning the same side
would always face it.
This side would be incredibly hot
while the shadow side would be frozen,
which makes it hard for life to develop
all new.
A planet with a big enough ocean might
be able to distribute this energy and
create some kind of stability.
All the gravitational forces at the red
dwarf could squeeze the canister and
heated up so much, but it might
lose all its water. Over time,
these planets could end up like Venus,
a hot burning hell.
Another problem is that many red
wolves vary in their energy output.
They can be covered in
star spots that condemned.
They're emitted light
by up to 40% for months,
which would cause oceans on planets
to freeze over at other times.
They can emit powerful solar flares,
sudden outbursts of energy,
incredibly powerful. These red dwarfs
can double their brightness in minutes,
which could strip away sizeable portions
of a planet's atmosphere and burn it,
rendering it sterile. On the other
hand, they're extremely long.
Lifespan is a big plus.
A red dwarf with just moderate levels of
activity could be an amazing place for
a pennant and hosts life.
Life on earth has existed for about 4
billion years and we have about a billion
years left before the sun becomes so hard
that complex life on earth will become
impossible. We will either die out or
leave earth and look for a new hope.
We could build a civilization
for potentially trillions
of years around a red
dwarf with the right conditions. About
5% of the red dwarfs in the Milky Way.
May host habitable roughly earth sized
planets that would be more than 4 billion
in total, but life may not
even need a planet like earth.
Candidates for life around a red dwarf,
maybe the moons of gas giants
also called super earths ready,
massive rocky planets.
All in all,
there are an estimated 60 billion
potentially habitable planets around red
dwarves,
and that's in the Milky Way alone.
So wolves might become really important
for our survival in the future,
but everything has to die at some point.
Even red dwarfs when
in trillions of years,
the life of the last Red Dwarf in
the university is about to end.
It will not be a very spectacular event.
As it's hundred runs,
outage shrinks becoming a blue dwarf,
burning out completely
after it's fueled is spent.
It's transformed into a white dwarf and
object about as smart as earth packed,
very densely and made of degenerate gases,
mostly of helion for nuclei.
Having no more source of energy,
it will cool extremely slowly
over trillions of years
until it becomes its final
format.
A cold,
blank dwarf white and Black Two offs are
so fascinating that they deserve their
own video anyway.
It's going to be a long time before the
last stars in the universe of vanish.
It's kind of uplifting to know that if
humanity succeeds in venturing into space,
we have plenty of time before the
universe turns out the lights,
Avocados a made thanks to your support
on patrion.com if you want to help us
make more of them,
we really appreciate your support.